[Music]
BDSM bondage and discipline domination
and Submission sadism and masochism a
kind of sex many read Fifty Shades of
Grey's fourth-grade prose to find out
about my tastes are very similar and the
subject of a scandal surrounding popular
Canadian radio host Jian Ghomeshi BDSM
is an erotic preference like any other
someone scented candles some want to get
whipped while biting a leather ball BDSM
can involve blindfolds ropes chains
harnesses whips handcuffs collars
leashes muzzles and other things Fifi
wishes she had a safe word for sea a
safe word is a special word you and your
partner have to call off the engagement
because apparently stop doesn't cut it
and the practice usually blurs the line
between pleasure and algae as BDSM
specialists and trainer Danna Rama
explains why do people do this like why
would anyone want to be hurt or hurt
people well the simple answer is that
for some people feels good but why am I
telling you about BDSM when it's show
NSFW because it's the subject of the
latest scandal to rock canada since
crack rock I mean Rob Ford how people
are taking cheap shots of me or this or
that
meet Jian Ghomeshi 47 year old host of
the super popular radio show Q of the
Canadian Broadcasting Corporation the
CBC recently fired him after learning he
may have sexually assaulted three former
girlfriends and harassed a co-worker Li
mu by taking the punches but Ghomeshi
claims he was just engaging in BDSM and
that there is a plot from a jilted lover
to get revenge one problem a key piece
of BDSM is consent agreement between
both parties to wit and receive
negotiate as to what is okay what you
like that involves the words you want to
be called that follows the types of
tools and toys you want to have used on
you and follows how you want to be
treated
it involves whether it's gonna be sex or
no sex all of that is discussed ahead of
time and according to months of
investigation by the Toronto Star there
wasn't in any of the cases there was
however alleged punching hitting
strangling and verbal abuse
none of it consensual according to those
interviews and
more women are accusing Ghomeshi of
assault too several have given accounts
of Ghomeshi
turning his teddy bear big ears around
just before he allegedly assaulted them
one of them is actress Lucy Deku Tara
she says there was no previous
discussion before gomez she slapped and
choked her while on a date and while
none of the women have pressed formal
charges the radio host is suing the CBC
for fifty five million dollars enough
for a lifetime supply of loot from the
Church of sin invention calm or just
some decent therapy so is Gomez she's
BDSM defense just simple BS and is he
joining a long line of famous men
accused but never convicted of behavior
that's more stink than pink one more
download the AJ plus mobile app and join
the conversation
available in your App Store now